THAT'S THREE STRAIGHT OFFENSIVE
FOULS, TWO ON THE NETS.
>> NUGGETS 3 POINTS IN THE THIRD
QUARTER.
MOST SINCE 2019 VERSUS CHICAGO.
PASS TO COUSINS.
AND COUSINS TRAVELS.
>> YOU GOTTA BE CAREFUL.
THAT'S TECHNICAL.
THAT'S THE SECOND ONE.
HE SLAMMED THE BALL AND NOW
BOOGIE COUSINS IS OUT OF THE
GAME.
CAN'T PUT THE BALL DOWN UNLESS
YOU CATCH IT.
>> HAD A TECHNICAL EARLIER AND
THAT WILL MEAN NIKOLA JOKIC BACK
IN.
>> HE GOT A TECHNICAL.
WHOEVER IS AT THE END OF THE
BENCH  --
>> AND COUSINS IS GOOD AND BAD
NEWS.
THE BAD NEWS IS HE WAS MAYING
WELL AND HE'S OUT.
THE GOOD NEWS NIKOLA JOKIC IS
BACK IN.
PATTY MILLS WILL SHOOT THE FREE
THROW.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN -- A LONG 43
SECONDS.
AND MILLS MISSES THE FREE THROW.
THEY ARE GOING TO CALL TRAVEL ON
BOOGIE.
HE LIFTED THAT